สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้
วัน
พุธ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 5 ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 4
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรค่ะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพอ
ส 2  5  6  6 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา 9 โมง
เมื่อกี้นี้มันไม่ได้ยินเสียงครูฟ้าเลย
อ่ะ 9 โมงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า
9 โมง 13 นาทีค่ะค่ะ 9 โมง 13 นาที
ครูฟ้าตื่นเช้านะคะ 9 โมง 13 ครูฟ้าตื่น
แล้ว
ใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าตื่นเช้าค่ะ
ตกใจค่ะ
ตกใจอะไรคะ
เพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยครูฟ้า
เมื่อก่อนน่ะครูฟ้าบอกว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น
นอน
บ่ายสองโมง
ใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนครูหญิง
นักเรียนบอกครูฟ้านอนอะไรขนาดนั้นหรอเอ้า
เมื่อก่อนครูฟ้ายังเด็กๆเด็กก็ต้องนอน
เยอะๆไง
ใช่
นักเรียน
ใช่ค่ะตอนนี้เนี่ย 9 โมง 13 นาทีเนี่ยเรา
ทำงานแล้วเราอัดวีดีโอแล้วถ้าอย่างนั้น
น่ะฟ้าก็ต้องตื่นตั้งแต่แบบอาจจะ 8 โมง
เช้า
8 โมงเช้า
ครูฟ้าตื่นแล้ว
หรือยังคะ
ตื่น
7 โมงค่ะครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงตกใจมากกว่าครูฟ้าตื่น 8 โมงอีกนะ
คะอุ้ยครูฟ้าตื่นเช้ามากผู้หญิงรู้แล้ว
ว่าทำไมครูฟ้าตื่นตั้งแต่
7 โมงเช้า
ทำไมอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าแก่แล้ว
ไงคะอ้าวก็อย่าง
เอ่อ
ผู้หญิงใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีคุณพ่อมีแม่นะคะแล้วก็มี
คุณตา
แล้วก็คุณยาย
คุณตาเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆนะผู้
หญิงอายุสัก 7 ขวบ
ครูหญิงเนี่ย 10 ขวบ
ก้อนเมื่อก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
เมื่อก่อนนานหน่อยกูฟ้ายังไม่เกิดนะผู้
หญิง 10 ขวบเนี่ยนะคะก็
คุณตาเนี่ยก็อายุประมาณ
60 สมมุติ
60 ใช่ไหมคุณยายก็อาจจะซัก
คุณยายผู้หญิงอายุน้อยกว่าคุณตายเยอะอ่ะ
อาจจะ 45 ไหม
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้นะคะแต่คุณตาเนี่ยอายุ 60
เนี่ยแก่แล้วคุณตาเนี่ยตื่นตั้งแต่
ตี 5
ทุกวัน
ตื่นตี 5 เลยเหรอใช่คุณยายเนี่ยก็ตื่นตี 5
คนที่เขาแก่แล้วเนี่ยเขาจะตื่นเช้ามากๆ
แต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นเด็กใช่ไหมอายุ 10
ขวบผู้หญิงตื่น 10 โมง
ผู้หญิงนะ
คะ
ได้อันนี้ไม่ไปโรงเรียนไงไม่ไปโรงเรียนก็
ตื่น 10 โมงแต่คุณตาคุณยายเนี่ยไม่ไปทำ
งานวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยก็ตื่นตี 5 ผู้
หญิงก็เลยคิด
คนที่เขาแก่แล้วเนี่ยเขาจะตื่นตั้งแต่
เช้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่น 7 โมงเช้า
ใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนครูฟ้าไม่ได้ตึก 7:00 น
ผู้หญิงก็เลยคิด
ถ้าครูฟ้าแก่แล้วผู้หญิงอะไรเนาะ
ผู้หญิงพูดแบบนี้ค่ะ
เอ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้แก่แล้วนะไม่ยัง
ก็ยังไม่ได้แก่เพราะว่าผู้หญิงไม่ได้อายุ
60 ปีใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนครูหญิงอายุยังไม่
ถึง 60 ปีเนาะแต่ว่าครูหญิงตอนนี้ปี 2018
ครูหญิงอายุผู้หญิงอายุเท่าไหร่คะ 38
เนาะครูฟ้า 28 ใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอ่าผู้หญิง
เนี่ยอายุ 38 ปีกับ
ย้อนไปตอน 2  0  1  3
ผู้หญิงอายุ 28 ใช่หรือเปล่าเนี่ยถูกเนาะ
10 ปีที่แล้ว
อะไรนะคะครูฟ้า
อายุมากแล้ว
จำไม่ได้
ใช่เริ่มแบบ
อะไรนะ
เริ่มคิดเริ่มเมื่อก่อนตอนอายุนิดหน่อยนะ
โอ้จำได้เลยจำถ้าเป็นเพื่อนกับครูฟ้าก็จำ
ได้ว่าครูฟ้าอายุเท่าไหร่เบอร์โทรศัพท์
ฟ้าเนี่ยเบอร์โทรศัพท์เนี่ยก็จำได้
แต่พออายุมากขึ้นมากขึ้นเนี่ยก็เริ่มจำ
ไม่ค่อยได้เริ่มเปลี่ยนแล้วไงเมื่อก่อน
ผู้หญิงอายุนิดหน่อยเนี่ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยนอน
3 ทุ่มผู้หญิงก็นอนแล้วเมื่อก่อน
ใช่แต่ตอนนี้
อายุมากขึ้นแล้วผู้หญิงนอนบางทีแบบ
นอนดึกมากนอน 5 ทุ่ม
7 โมงเช้าตื่นแล้ว
7:00 นก็ตื่นแล้ว
เห็นไหมพอเราอายุมากขึ้นมากขึ้นเนี่ยเรา
ก็เริ่มไม่เหมือนเดิม
นอนไม่เหมือนเดิมใช่ไหมกินไม่เหมือนเดิม
ไม่ได้เลย
ใช่หรือว่าบางทีในกระเป๋าเนาะเราก็จะมี
กระเป๋าใช่ไหมเป็นเราเป็นผู้หญิงอ่ะเราก็
มีกระเป๋าเวลาที่เราจะออกไปข้างนอกบ้าน
ตอนครูหญิงอายุ 18 ปีอายุ 25 ปีในกระเป๋า
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็มีโทรศัพท์นะ
[เพลง]
มี
18 ปีในกระเป๋ามีทิชชู่
ผู้หญิง
มีสลิป
มี
ทิชชู่เปียกอย่างนี้
เมื่อก่อนครูหญิงไม่มีเลยนะแต่พออายุมาก
ขึ้นเนี่ย
พกทิชชู่
พกทิชชู่เปียกอย่างนี้ค่ะครูฟ้าอยู่ใน
กระเป๋า
ครูหญิงคะ
งั้นครูฟ้าก็แก่ตั้งแต่อายุ 7 ขวบนะคะนัก
เรียน
เพราะว่า
พวกเรามีกระเป๋าใหญ่มากนะคะ
เวลาครูฟ้าไปไหน
อีกอย่างนึงนะคะครูฟ้าที่แบบทำให้รู้ว่า
เนี่ยเราอายุมากขึ้นก็คือกระเป๋าของเรา
เนี่ยมันจะใหญ่มากขึ้นมันเปิดมามันจะมี
ของๆๆอยู่ในกระเป๋ามากๆ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงคือฟ้ามีของในกระเป๋าเยอะ
มากๆนะคะ
อื้มตอนนี้ก็ของเยอะมากๆเหมือนกันนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะแล้วของในกระเป๋าตอนที่เราอายุมาก
ขึ้นกับตอนที่เราอายุนิดหน่อยเนี่ยก็จะ
ไม่เหมือนกันอย่างผู้หญิงก็มีทิชชู่ใช่
ไหมคะมีทิชชู่ในกระเป๋ามี
ทิชชู่เปียกแต่ว่าบางคนเนี่ยเขาก็อาจจะมี
อันนี้ผู้หญิงไม่มีหรอกนะแต่ผู้หญิงคิด
ว่าหลายๆคนมีไหม
ยาดม
ครูฟ้าซื้อยาดมมาออสเตรเลียด้วยนะคะน้อง
เรียน
แต่ครูฟ้าทำหาย
ครูฟ้าต้องนั่งเครื่องบิน
นั่งเครื่องบินจากออสเตรเลียแล้วก็กลับมา
ที่ประเทศไทย
อันนี้นะคะนักเรียนอันนี้ทั้งหมดนี้คือยา
ดมนะเนี่ยยาดม
ฝั่งนี้ก็คือยาดมส่วนตรงกลางเนี่ยนะคะก็
เปิดดมได้
ทาได้นะคะเขาบอกว่าเวลาที่เราอายุมากขึ้น
เราเนี่ยจะพกยาดม
จริงหรอ
ทำไมอ่ะแต่ครูฟ้ายังเด็กอยู่ครูฟ้าก็มียา
ดมเนาะอุปมาก็ไม่เด็กแล้วนะคะ
จะ 30 แล้วนะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงตกใจนะคะผู้หญิงเห็นครูฟ้าตั้งแต่
อายุ 20 เท่าไหร่
แต่ว่าครูฟ้าอายุ 28 ก็ยังแบบยังไม่ได้ก็
ยังเป็นโอเคยังเลข 2 อยู่
ไม่ได้โตมากใช่ไหมอย่างผู้หญิงก็ครูฟ้าจะ
30 ครูหญิงจะ 40 แล้วเมื่อก่อนตอนผู้
หญิงเด็กๆผู้หญิงก็ไม่พกยาดมค่ะผู้หญิง
ไม่ดมยาดม
มันก็ไม่ดมนะคะเมื่อก่อน
แต่ตอนนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบยาดมมากนะคะนัก
เรียน
อาจจะแบบไม่ค่อยชอบยาดมเท่าไหร่นะแต่
อันเนี้ยครูฟ้าอ่ะไอ้ยาที่มันแบบเป็นขวด
แบบนี้แล้วก็เปิดมาแล้วก็ดมก็ได้ทาก็ได้
อ่ะผู้หญิงก็ที่บ้านมีที่คอนโดมิเนียม
เนี่ยมีนะคะบางครั้งก็รู้สึกว่าเออเปิดมา
แล้วก็มาดมทำไมมันก็รู้สึกดีเนอะอันนี้
เป็นเพราะว่าเรา
อายุมากขึ้นหรือเปล่า
ใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเพราะว่าเราอายุมากขึ้นนะคะ
แต่ว่าเพราะว่าเราเหนื่อยง่ายไง
ใช่เมื่อก่อนตอนเราเด็กๆเดินๆๆก็ไม่
เหนื่อย
แต่ตอนนี้เราเหนื่อยแล้วก็
ดมยาดม
ใช่ไหมคะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าดมไหมตอนนี้เนี่ยครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยทำยาดมหายไปแล้ว
ไหวไหมคะโอเคไหมเวลาเดินๆๆแล้วก็เหนื่อย
เพราะอยากไปซื้อยาดมใหม่นะคะ
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงซื้อ
แล้วก็ใส่
ใส่กล่องโอเคไหม
เป็นแพ็คเกจแล้วก็ส่งจากประเทศไทยไป
ออสเตรเลีย
ขอบคุณมากค่ะคุณหญิง
30,000 บาทค่ะ
แพง
ขอ
บอกว่ายาดมนะคะบางคนเนี่ยที่แบบตอนอายุ
น้อยๆเนี่ยไม่ได้ดมยาดมพออายุมากขึ้นก็จะ
เริ่มมียาดมเนี่ยอยู่ในกระเป๋าอืมหรือว่า
เริ่มพกยาดมนะคะแต่ว่าอันต่อไปเนี่ย
อันนี้แล้วกันครูฟ้ารู้ไหมครูฟ้ามีไหมคะ
ที่บ้านครูฟ้ายังไม่มีอ่ะผู้หญิงรู้ว่า
ยังไม่มีนะคะ
ตอนแรกผู้หญิงก็แบบตอนตอนครูหญิงเด็กๆนะ
คะคุณตาคุณหญิงชอบมากเลยนะ
อันนี้หรอ
วันนี้พ่อแม่ใช่ไหมนักเรียนเนี่ยพ่อแม่
แล้วก็คนนี้คุณตา
คุณตาอายุ 60 ปีใช่คุณตาเนี่ยชอบเอามา
มันจะฉีกซองได้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วมันก็จะมีแผ่น
อันนี้สีขาวๆเนี่ยค่ะนักเรียนแล้วก็แปะ
ใช่แปะที่ต้นแขนแตะที่หลังเนี่ยแปะไป
เนี่ยนะคะคุณตาผู้หญิงเนี่ยแปะๆๆที่หลัง
เยอะมากๆแล้วตอนผู้หญิงเด็กๆอ่ะผู้หญิงก็
ไม่ชอบ
กลิ่นเหม็นไม่ชอบมันมันมีกลิ่นนะ
ใช่ๆค่ะมันมีกลิ่นไงแล้วครูหญิงยังเด็ก
ใช่ไหมอาจจะอายุสัก 10 ขวบอย่างนี้ค่ะยัง
เด็กก็จะแบบทำไมคุณตาแปะเขาเรียกอะไรนะ
แผ่นแปะแก้ปวดนะคะเพราะว่าคุณตาเนี่ยแก่
แล้วบางทีแบบปวดปวดปวดใช่ไหมปวดหลังอย่าง
นี้ปวดหลังก็แปะที่หลังปวดบ่าแปะที่บ่า
ใช่เป็นแผ่นแปะแก้ปวดนะคะแต่สัก 3 ปีที่
แล้วไม่คุยกับอายุประมาณ 35 ปีมั้ง
ผู้หญิงก็เคยมีที่บ้านไงมีที่
คอนโดมิเนียมก็แบบเริ่มรู้สึกแบบเออปวด
อ่ะปวดที่บ่าก็เลยเริ่มฉีกแล้วก็เอามาแปะ
ดูแล้วก็รู้สึก
มันดีนะ
มันจะเย็นๆก่อนไงมันจะมีแบบเย็นอันเนี้ย
อย่างอันนี้ใช่ไหมภาษาอังกฤษนะเป็นแบบ
เย็นแล้วมันจะมีแบบร้อนเนาะครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบแบบร้อนแบบร้อนเนี่ยไม่โอเคแบบเย็น
เนี่ยโอเคแต่ดีนะโอเค
คนอายุมากหลายๆคนเนี่ยชอบซื้อนะคะ
จริงหรอเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าร้องนะคะลองซื้อ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าที่ออสเตรเลียก็มีขายแต่น่า
จะแพง
อาจจะมีอาจจะแพงนะคะแต่ว่าไม่รู้ว่า
แต่อันนี้มันเป็น
ของไทยค่ะของไทย
เพราะว่าใช่อันนี้เนี่ยเขาจะมียี่ห้อนี้
ใช่ไหมยี่ห้อตราเสือเนี่ยเขาจะมี
ยาหม่องด้วยไง
เขาไม่ได้มีแค่แผ่นแปะแก้ปวดใช่ไหมเขาจะ
มียาหม่องซึ่งผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าไอ้ยาหม่อง
เนี่ยนะคะ
เวลาเปิดออกมามันก็จะเป็นเหมือนบามอ่ะ
เหมือนบามแต่ว่ามันจะมีกลิ่นหน่อย
มัน
นะเวลาปวดปวดบ่าใช่ไหมคะถ้าไม่ได้ใช้แผ่น
แปะแก้ปวดก็เอายาหม่องเนี่ยทา
แก้ปวดได้อันนี้ก็คนอายุมากขึ้นก็จะใช้
กลิ่นมันไม่หอมไง
ใช่ค่ะหรือว่าเขาบอกว่าบางคนใช่ไหมคะ
อย่างครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่แว่นอยู่
แล้วอันนี้ไม่เป็นไรเราอายุน้อยอายุมากๆ
เราก็ใส่แว่นแต่บางคนที่เขาอายุน้อยๆเขา
ไม่ได้ใส่แว่นพออายุมากขึ้นมากขึ้นเนี่ย
ตาของเราใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ไม่ใช่คุณตาแล้วนะนักเรียน
แต่
เนี่ยนะตอนเราอายุนิดหน่อยเนี่ยนะคะเรามี
หนังสือ
กระดาษเนี่ยก็เราก็อ่านไม่ใส่แว่นแล้ว
อ่านโอเคแต่พอเราอายุหุ้น
เขาเรียกว่าตามันยาว
อย่างผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้า
ใช่ผู้หญิงคือฟ้าตั้งใส่แว่นตั้งแต่เด็ก
เนี่ยตาสั้นใช่ไหมตาสั้นต้องดูใกล้ๆก็เลย
ใส่แว่นเนี่ยโอเคแต่เวลาเราอายุมากขึ้น
สักจริงอย่างผู้หญิงตอนนี้อ่ะผู้หญิงอายุ
38 เนี่ยตาก็ไม่ได้ยาวนะคะแต่เวลาตัว
หนังสือถ้าเขียนแบบ a โอเค
a โอเคแต่ถ้าแบบ
เขียนแบบตัวเล็กๆเนี่ยเริ่มมองไม่เห็น
แล้วนะคะ
สมมติตัวหนังสือมันเล็ก
ต้องดูดีๆมันเล็กมากนะครูฟ้าครูฟ้ายังไม่
เป็นหรอกครูฟ้าอายุน้อยใช่แต่บางคนเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ใส่แว่นใช่ไหมพออายุมากขึ้นเนี่ยตา
เนี่ยมันจะยาวมันจะดูแบบ
เวลาจะอ่านอะไรก็ต้องพกแว่นสมัยก็จะมี
แว่นเอาไว้อ่านหนังสือก็จะใส่แว่นแต่ถ้า
ในชีวิตประจำวันก็ไม่ได้ใส่แว่นเนี่ยแหละ
ค่ะเขาก็บอกว่าเป็นของนะคะที่แบบว่าหรือ
อะไรที่มันจะเปลี่ยนไปเมื่อเราเนี่ยอายุ
มากขึ้นก็อันนี้แบบคนไทยอ่ะนะคะก็เลยเอา
มาคุยให้นักเรียนฟังเนาะส่วนวีดีโอนี้นะ
คะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าไปก่อนเนาะแล้วเดี๋ยว
เราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]